No, you can't.
Score!
Just go around, everybody flub, flub, flub, flub, flub.
They were too slow.
They need quicker rocks.
Dude, their defense is firing on them.
They need to, they have no, it's literally, they have nothing slow in their defense now.
That's a way too flabby defense.
Why would you do that?
That was a horrible decision.
Did you steal that?
Yeah, took the balls out.
He just went around and around.
I said the ball was out.
Spin it now.
Spin it.
Get through.
Pop it.
Oh, my God, guys.
That's selfish.
That's really selfish.
He's playing it safe.
Just another rock.
Just go.
There we go.
Go quick.
They're out.
It's close.
It's hard.
For sure.
They can score.
They can still score here, though.
Yeah, you're right.
I know.
With only seven, I think it's a good one.
At least it looks better.
That looks just fine.
Well, you can't win them all.
But let's see.
Let's see if you can get a try.
Come on, boys.
Nice.
Good take.
Quick.
You've got to run a line right to the post.
You have to go now, guys.
Urgency.
Go.
Bro, the scrum half is way too quiet.
Oh, man.
Too hot.
Oh, no.
Why?
What?
No, this you can smell it.
It's the man.
It's the it's the ë† candy.
Great.
That's right.
Yeah.
It's gum.
That's a good first game, bro.
That's a good game.
That's another good game.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Yeah, yeah, it's a good game right.
Happy Thanksgiving.
I can't believe that.